difficile décidément pour le rpr et
l'udf de tirer des plans sur la
cohabitation tout paraissait pourtant
réglé au rpr jacques chirac en réserve
des élections présidentielles à l'udf
valéry giscard d'estaing réservé sur la
cohabitation
cohabitation dur ou poly l'opposition
s'interrogeait schéma trop simple pour
faire ta donc il faut aller au
gouvernement
lâche ce serait du fait du non pas
que jacques chirac soit menée assumer
lui même les fonctions je crois qu'ils
ne le souhaitent pas est-ce qu'il n'y
sera pas obligé
7,97 une autre affaire et nous verrons
ça au
lendemain des élections à l'udf aussi
changement de cap pour valéry giscard
d'estaing cohabiter c'était un piège
pour l'opposition mais depuis peu
certains de ses lieutenants comme hervé
de charette évoque ouvertement
l'hypothèse d'un giscard premier mini
des qualités
situation
à deux mois des législatives
une course à matignon par s engager sans
attendre celle des présidentielles et au
risque de voir les duos de l'opposition
se transformer en duel au sommet